hey guys I'm Ryan right I'm Jerry today
we're checking out a trailer for a video
game Super Smash Brothers Wii U what
they're doing a Ryu character apparently
that's I wanted to check this out people
send it to me and we were literally just
talking about Street Fighter II did so
yeah we were just so I do you want to
check this out ASAP Jerry shut your
[ __ ] move as Dez thing cooks it shut
your mouth shut your mouth choose comic
mischeif cartoon violence mild
suggestive things s vinaigrettes though
yeah so cool the perfect character for
Super Smash
let's keep expecting
here we go he's perfect for this game
all I wish be some gameplay footage oh
oh yeah we're gonna get this is smash oh
yes perfect
no marios wasting
buta looks like Street Fighter 1 Super
Smash
must defeat my sure you can just stand a
chance
hi I love super smell a the five
that's exactly Hachi I don't know I
don't think it's a Hachi it looked like
hey Asha I woke with black hair and some
prayer it did look like a Hachi
but like them the me version no I'm
rockin yeah I don't know but no dude I
[ __ ] love Super Smash I don't know if
the games already available I mean I
know the games me I don't know if Ryu's
ready available or if he's like deals
yeah I don't know but I'd no idea you
could use Rio or Ryu whichever one you
want say Ryu since since Street Fighter
2 turbo that was the Paolo's introduced
was part 2 turbo ever since that game
and as many characters as they keep
bringing in Ryu always remains my
favorite and not just because everyone
else loves him he's just always been my
favorite I do have a connection with the
character especially because I watched
the street fighter two animated movie it
sucks because the real life movie right
never got proper service and ken was
played by damien Chapa the American
colonel was played by French actor John
loved it anyway but ya know that looks
[ __ ] awesome Ryu is the perfect
character for Super Smash Brothers like
the controller is gonna be a lot easier
to do the three main [ __ ] moves
everybody does yeah so yeah cuz I cut
the shuriken
oh wait like that is always the one I
suck at so there it's super smash
controller so I'm finally to be able to
do it like no problem yeah anyway guys
thanks for sending this my way man I was
awesome if you're new to the channel you
can subscribe to the real rejects bucum
and you can check out Jerry's show on
this channel now Gordon Han and you can
follow us on Facebook Instagram Twitter
and vine well do the people say
Piku Jim Paris
Josh rated irelia relia second rise
second on my Jurassic world review Brian
I want a shout-out don't have Facebook
and don't want it you guys are [ __ ]
awesome I rarely go to the comments to
actually get the shout outs because it's
no it's only usually through the
Facebook a yeah for sure but Josh
comments a lot he doesn't have a
Facebook he doesn't care for one so Josh
I wanted to say thank you for following
us you're a great guy
Josh Rell yeah more like Josh hell yeah
they come in big [ __ ] Josh big [ __ ] Josh
hell yeah um big [ __ ] [ __ ] a dog dog
Josh hell yeah hell yeah to the
[ __ ] yeah dad sure uh-huh why
not this is your customized shout out
appreciate it